hello and welcome to this video playing
al-khatib initial master I'll car tape
name there haha tip armata beat living
in qatar now ok this is cut on here yeah
ok so which was posed to the bank oh and
let's see what he is coming up with ok
this is a rare way to do it the night
doesn't really have a great spot on a
form hmm I can try to somehow regroup it
with be three things like that but it
takes time I can go Bishop d7 and just
take a turn for this point structured
damage I wonder if that is an idea and
the bishop is usually not all that great
anyway so maybe do it it's about it's a
bit of a controversial decision because
this night isn't is a bad piece but my
bishop is also not great and this a pawn
this weekend this will be porn for white
seems he wants to put the night to put
three hand on b3 hmm well that's
possible if he gets to a five then it's
difficult to attack this actually ok I
think I'm going with this putting a
knight on c3 cannot be all that bad
not sure if it is doing all that much to
be perfectly honest but it looks like in
a piece like an annoying piece to to
live with so what can I do here um I can
try to attack you see for porn mmm skin
it's difficult to get at this the a5
pawn really feels difficult to do mmm
they SAT night all that great I don't
know this is also a controversial
decision but I want some space here
control the center
if he goes f4 is giving up control here
and here i have pawn to you for I
thought that this could be interesting
let's do it I mean he has to take
basically otherwise i'm pushing f3 and
this looks terrible and here the rook
has some options actually attacking see
for the night also is strongly 522 f 3
it would be a funky idea oh wow wow
isn't that somewhat dangerous for you
what do I overlooked here I don't even
see where the bishop is going now going
to e to ie for Hitler get lost I can
take a tick b3 it's a full night
hmm ok I have to muta video for a second
now i'm back i got a call that i had to
take so luke t 1 yeah it was difficult
they are not to give a material here
group 2 1 and now what to do I wonder I
mean this looks kind of okay yeah it
looks very controlled i think i'm
thinking of route takes a five given
giving this up and just to break through
yeah i will have an extra pause after
that and excellent control
yeah so is he actually threatening to
take it from the yes Roxy three looks
like a normal option here mmm if I go
back and then F for its kind of that's
that's an annoyance so I can actually
play roots III try to check c4 make it a
bit trickier for him I am now F for
coming okay then I can prevent with
Queen a three let's just do it like that
and they have maybe B 3 and so on okay
let's see it's not all that easy here on
the sudden yes this isn't it tells
attacked hmm okay i'm dropping back
covering it I still have the B porn that
I can push forward this also looks it to
whether as a move that I can play next
cap it's helpful like the signs now that
that position out of the opening I think
air was already kind of doubtful here um
yeah I don't know 93 is a somewhat
strange move because you get to misplace
your night for no particular reason okay
this Bishop d7 and taking is that is
somewhat debatable because the night is
really not a good piece yeah but I just
think that the structure that I
gaddis is a niacin the a porn is more of
a weakness and I'm getting rid of my
light squared Bishop which is
notoriously useless in the bank oh so
that cannot be bad yet him I got to this
situation with the knight on c3 I think
it is a still somewhat annoying piece
for y tu tu tu tu fais so I think it's
an ok ok ok idea it's interesting that
the engine wants to play 6 cm I mean
looking at this now it makes an awful
lot of sense because after this you get
the get stuff like this going on at D 5
D 5 is actually nicely protected by the
night and there is no roop d1 coming
here because the knight on c3 is so
strong and that looks very good yeah
that's very good idea ok I think this
isn't isn't bad either but it six is
just a far more dynamic option and here
the problem is he cannot relate he
doesn't really have something great
available something like f4 check I'm
taking in the night no mods has control
over this year 6 for example a new key 8
taking next is very strong and no
efforts in interesting try I mean that
tries to establish the e5 Knight for a
longer time the computer hates the move
therefore it wants to play 6 yeah that
is probably a stronger idea something
that I totally miss evaluated during the
game ya know g3 this is disastrous yep
he has no move now he has something like
that blonde is quite a bit of stuff and
night see one I can take 85 and he's
totally tied down him it's pretty awful
he had this ok I took it and now Queen
85 is a pragmatic decision it's not
necessary the engine wants to play Queen
c8 Queen f5 later Quincy 8 queer a queen
a five if the bishop moves
because i don't know i think this is a
simple way of doing it yeah maybe I
could have done something more active
but i just wanted to prevent f4 which
gets tackled with this now queen age for
Queen 287 yeah it's still full control
and I can't go B 3 and so on it should
be a relatively easy win okay thanks for
watching